bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 4 novembre à moins
de deux mois des fêtes de fin d'année
les magasins de jouets essayer de
s'adapter face à ce deuxième confinement
qui court jusqu'au 1er décembre une
boutique de plaisir a mis en place un
drive et la livraison à domicile
elle témoigne dans l'actualité également
l'église catholique a décidé de déposer
un référé contre l'interdiction des
rassemblements au sein des lieux de
culte bruno valentin évêque auxiliaire
de versailles exprimera ses inquiétudes
quant à la pratique de la foi pendant le
confinement est depuis lundi 2 novembre
les tests antigénique sont arrivés en
pharmacie
une nouvelle tâche pour les
professionnels l'exemple d'un pharmacien
de montigny le bretonneux et aussi dans
les yvelines les réactions des expatriés
suite aux élections aux états unis ciom
mais juste avant cela lundi 2 novembre
un trafiquant de drogue originaire de
trappes ainsi que ses quatre acolytes
ont été mis en examen à versailles puis
écroués dans des prisons francilienne
ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir organisé un
trafic international de cannabis et de
cocaïne provenant notamment d'amérique
du sud est du maroc
c'est l'interpellation à l'aéroport
d'orly d'une mule venue de guyane qui a
permis d'arrêter les individus elle
transportait 124 boulettes de cocaïne
dans le ventre
après halloween ce sont les fêtes de fin
d'année qui arrive à grands pas les
vendeurs de jouets considérés comme non
essentiels ont dû fermer leurs portes
pendant ce deuxième confinement il se
réorganise
à l'image d'un magasin de plaisir
reportage de bixente mais rien senti
steban sait déjà les fêtes pour cette
enseigne de jouets de plaisir ne pouvoir
recevoir de clients un drive ainsi qu un
click and collect ont été mises en place
pour préparer noël
on est là pour satisfaire des milliers
d'enfants en parle de noël c'est notre
notre coeur de métier c'est notre adn
c'est l'adn de picwic toys pour cela
c'est une organisation reprise du
premier confinement adapté pour la forte
affluence habituelle de fin d'année pour
nous ça a été facile parce qu'on était
déjà armé
on a l'habitude de se préparer à une
saison de jouir ce surcroît d'activité
on le connaît on anticipe donc on a
gonflé nos stocks on a compté nos
équipes on a fait un catalogue puissant
avec de nombreuses offres
on tourne à 16 personnes sur notre
magasin c'est de traiter un volume de 2
200 commandes jours les clients prennent
rendez vous devant la boutique pour la
remise de leur commande presse comme en
propre avec un grave en commandant c'est
quand même assez facile pour nous pour
aller chercher les cadeaux de noël
c'est déjà assez triste comme ça donc je
pense que pour les enfants ça c'est
quand même bien que ils ont leur jouer
quand même de noël que ce soit
évidemment lors de contacts
téléphoniques sms ou lors de remises des
produits en drive on peut dire que
malgré le port du masque
les sourires sont perceptibles et plein
de sincérité et de réciprocité ça c'est
vraiment le plaisir au quotidien
bien que vides de clientèle la vie
continue à l'intérieur du magasin
puisque les employés s'attelle également
à prendre les commandes en ligne et
préparer les livraisons à domicile donc
l'organisation à l'etrat nous avons des
collaborateurs qui seront à pikine
grands magasins et ramène le produit ici
à partir de là il ya un rapprochement
qui s'opère on édite un bon de livraison
et un
on d'expédition conduit le produit en
carton on est de bons dit voyons on
ferme le carton bon d'expédition et
c'est parti une organisation prévue pour
sauver noël
en attendant de savoir si le magasin
pourra rouvrir début décembre dans la
même thématique les libraires considérés
eux aussi comme converse non essentiels
sont évidemment impacté par le
confinement
patrice carmouze directeur de
l'information de tv 78 s'est entretenu
avec une professionnelle de viroflay on
les écoute
nous savons que les librairies ne sont
pas considérés comme des magasins de
première nécessité malheureusement mais
on peut quand même aller acheter des
livres en librairie on va en parler avec
à mme blandine de la rivière bonjour
bonjour vous êtes libraire à viroflay
votre libéré s'appelle une page de vie
en effet vous est fermé mais vous est
ouverte si je peux d'ici alors on est
fermé c'est à dire que personne ne peut
rentrer dans nos locaux mais on a
instauré un système de click and collect
qui permet au rang de commenter soit par
mail soit par téléphone est devenu
chercher leurs rivaux sur le pas de la
porte
alors on se connecte au site internet
des libres et de la vôtre par exemple
nous page de vie et là on peut acheter
comment ça se passe et c'est pas encore
de site internet nous avec le
référencement de tout notre stock on est
en train de s'y employer mais c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu long et par
contre les personnes qui veulent faire
une commande nous envoie un mail sur
notre adresse mail et nous on leur dit
si soit on l'a en stock soit on peut le
commander
à l'heure actuelle c'est vrai que tous
les entrepôts fonctionne donc ont pu
être livrés tous les jours jusqu'à
maintenant que ça continue vous avez
parlé avec vos autres collègues libres
est est ce que vous regrettez au fond la
décision qui était de dire on ferme les
librairies
alors que le livre est important pendant
cette période de confinement oui je
pense que le livre est essentielle
cependant pourquoi nous et pas d'autres
c'est vrai que la décision est compliqué
à prendre
on voit déjà que ce deuxième confinement
ne ressemble pas du tout au premier
c'est difficile je ne sais pas trop quoi
penser
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur c'est ce
qu'on dit beaucoup que au fond le
premier koffi de moi beaucoup proposent
de profiter aux gaffes et notamment
amazon est ce que vous n'avez pas peur
que ce deuxième confinement soit encore
plus dur pour les petits commerçants
dont vous faites partie
alors c'est évident on ne pourra jamais
concurrencer une entreprise comme amazon
en revanche on a nous la chance de la
voie des clients fidèles qui ont envie
de nous faire travailler et qui ont
envie d'avoir une vie locale qui
continue après un jour on sera plus
confiné pour ça il faut nous faire
travailler et on a un réseau de clients
et de nouveaux clients qui ce qui
augmente et ça nous fait chaud au coeur
oui c'est zahia une sorte de réflexe un
peu entre guillemets patriotique le dire
a laissé les libraires fait les
travailler parce que c'est quand même
mieux que les grandes plateformes
internationales
donc voilà le clien collecte continue
pendant plein dans le pendant le
confinement et donc on peut se procurer
des livres dans les librairies c'est ça
le message essentiel qu'il faut qu'il
faut faire passer exactement c'est
patrice merci beaucoup blandine de la
rivière anne blandine de la rivière
pardon merci
en soutien à ces commerces non
essentiels c'est président du
département d'île de france ont envoyé
une lettre au premier ministre jean
castex aux côtés des hauts-de-seine de
l'essonne du val d'oise de
seine-saint-denis du val-de-marne et de
la scène emma le département des
yvelines a lui aussi signé cet écrit
dans la lettre les élus s'inquiètent
notamment des conséquences du
confinement sur l'économie locale et le
commerce de proximité
le président des yvelines pierre bédier
explique son choix au micro de mélanie
poké on a eu tous les présents de
conseils départementaux la même remonter
qu'un avec des maires nous alertant des
commerçants qu'on connaît mais n'diaye
tonnes ou même en allant faire nos
courses
c'était mon cas moi quand j'ai fait le
constat mentent tous les commerçants
étaient effarés la décision illogique
été prise car encore une fois c'est
illogique
[Musique]
oui la règle ça doit être la liberté
on voit bien que les clusters les fameux
klosters ont pas dans les petits
commerces c'est pas vrai toutes les
précautions sanitaires sont prises
les gens attendent à l'extérieur y'a
jamais plus de deux personnes dans le
magasin ils portent le masque
les gens ne sont pas fous le petit
commerçant il sait bien que si lui
attrape le coc vide personne tiendra la
boutique pour lui puisqu'il est souvent
son propre patron et 130 employés
je vais résumer les choses un petit
nombre ont mis la clé sous la porte sont
pas encore très nombreux
je pense que si ils sont confinés pour
noël il y aura une hécatombe qui ne
réouvrira pas mais alors vraiment pas en
janvier et même si c'est ouvert pour
pour noël on risque d'avoir de très près
mais surprise en ramener une lettre
restée sans réponse de la part du
premier ministre pour le monde et dans
le cadre de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
les célébrations mis à part les obsèques
sont interdites au titre de la liberté
du culte
la conférence des évêques de france
demande à ce que l'interdiction des
messes publiques soient levés
plusieurs évêques se sont associés à
cette démarche il souhaite que les
messes du dimanche soit considérée parmi
les motifs dérogatoire de sortie en
écoute monseigneur bruno valentin évêque
auxiliaire de versailles
des propos recueillis par justine
brasier monseigneur brno valentin
bonjour bonjour vous êtes évêque
auxiliaire du diocèse de versailles
alors on va bien sûr parler un peu de
l'organisation des églises pendant le
confinement
mais avant ça j'aimerais revenir un peu
sur le courrier qui est adressée au
président de la république et notamment
par le président de la conférence des
évêques de france qui demandait à ce que
les messes du dimanche devienne un motif
en tout cas dérogatoires pour sortir où
on en est aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
forcément le cas c'est ça alors le
président de la conférence des évêques
de france a demandé trois choses au
présent la république
d'abord c'est que contrairement au
confinement précédent les aumôniers
et toujours accès aux hôpitaux pour
s'occuper des malades et ça ça a été
accordé il faut souligner deuxièmement
il a demandé que la fête de la toussaint
ne soit pas entravée et là encore ça a
été accordé il faut le reconnaître est
effectivement troisièmement il a demandé
que pendant la durée du confinement la
messe du dimanche reste une possibilité
au titre des déplacements dérogatoire et
ça le le gouvernement l'a refusée on a
dialogué un certain temps avec le
gouvernement jusque arrière et comme
hier nous a été signifié un refus
définitif
eh bien nous avons décidé de nous
tourner vers le conseil d'état est
d'introduire un référé liberté pour
demander au conseil d'état d'annuler
cette interdiction est justement vous
demander d'annuler cette interdiction
est ce qu'on peut faire un point
peut-être sur les rassemblements qui
sont autorisés ce qu'ils ne sont pas
tout rassemblement dans l'église est
interdite à l'exception des obsèques
jusqu'à 30 personnes
voilà et donc la situation et celle ci
aujourd'hui vous pouvez dans votre
promenade quotidienne assez à l'église
mais il est plus possible par exemple y
célébrer la messe quoi dit célébrer
autres sacrements justement à l'heure
actuelle qu'est ce que vous attendez des
prochaines mesures à suivre bien nous
demandons au conseil d'état que il
annule cette interdiction on est que au
fond nous puissions en rester aux cadres
de la laïcité parce que la laïcité c'est
un principe d' équilibre réciproque les
cultes ne doivent pas se mêler du
fonctionnement de l'état mais également
et c'est moins connu
l'état ne peut pas se mêler du
fonctionnement des cultes voilà en
laïcité
le rôle de l'état c'est de garantir
l'exercice du culte et tante entendue
que ça ne doit pas aller contre l'ordre
public
or nous nous sommes en capacité de
garantir l'ordre sanitaire de nos
célébrations parce que les fidèles
portent des masques
parce que nous distribuons du gel
hydroalcoolique à l'entrée dans les
églises
parce que nous respectons les distances
entre les chaises qui nous sont imposés
donc nous sommes en capacité de garantir
la sécurité sanitaire et dès lors il
nous sommes que l'état sort de son rôle
en interne ni culte merci pour ces
précisions à monseigneur bruno valentin
vous l'avez donc compris si les
célébrations ne sont pour l'heure plus
possible les églises
elle reste ouverte il est donc toujours
possible de s'y rendre
bien sûr sans dépasser l'heure et en
respectant le rayon d'un kilomètre et
l'actualité c'est aussi les tests anti
génie qui sont arrivés en pharmacie
depuis lundi 2 novembre
ils doivent permettre de soulager les
laboratoires et donc de mon tester avec
des tests pcr reportage d'astrid bergère
les tests antigénique sont arrivés
depuis lundi 2 novembre il est désormais
possible d'aller se faire tester en
pharmacie une nouvelle tâche confiée par
le gouvernement qui doit permettre de
désengorger les laboratoires mais c'est
d'être réactif et chassa dans des bonnes
conditions
c'est à dire qu'on fait passer n'importe
comment on a été formé pour ce geste par
une par une infirmière qui est venu deux
journées entières pour nous former au
pour nous former aux gestes
donc on
donc on essaie de répondre présent à la
nouvelle mission qui nous est confiée
dans le but de gérer au maximum cette
crise sanitaire
ces tests se font sans rendez-vous et
gratuitement dans les pharmacies
ils ont pourtant un coût pour les
professionnels les tests sont à notre
charge le matériel est à notre charge
heureusement le
le sens commercial a pu nous mettre à
disposition un local qui nous permet de
réaliser ces tests dans de bonnes
conditions sanitaires depuis que la
pharmacie de montigny a démarré les
tests environ 10% et personnes ont été
testées positives entre 50 et 70
personnes viennent se faire dépister
chaque jour je me suis fait tester parce
que notre employeur nous demande de le
faire
moi je me suis déjà fait tester une
première fois parce que j'avais des
symptômes or c'était pas ça et là c'est
parce qu'on a plusieurs cas dans notre
équipe
c'est rassurant et puis ça évite de
perdre du temps et de s'inquiéter de
s'angoisser dans 72 heures plus rapide
que les tests pcr les tests antigénique
sont pourtant basé sur le même principe
un prélèvement nasal la différence il
recherche la protéine du virus et non
pas son génome les résultats sont alors
accessibles en moins de 30 minutes on
prend maintenant la direction du chéné
rocancourt le centre commercial parly 2
a mis en place depuis la mi-octobre un
centre de dépistage du coc vite 19
chaque jour une centaine de personnes se
fait dépister les précisions de michael
et demi d'euros il ne passe pas inaperçu
le long de la rd 181 6 5 centres de
dépistage du coc vite 19 a été installé
sur l'un des parkings extérieurs de
parly 2 du côté de l'arboretum de
chèvreloup une initiative lancée depuis
le 19 octobre dernier en partenariat
avec la ville du fener au concours donc
on a été sollicité la mairie la ville du
coup du chesnay rocancourt en lui
proposant de leur mettre à disposition
un terrain
puisqu'on en a de disponible et puis en
fait oui ce fils parly 2 c'est aussi un
point névralgique des yvelines donc
c'était une façon d'accueillir en fait
les personnes les patients pour cette
unité mobile plus facile 6 jours sur 7
entre 100 et 120 personnes se font
dépister gratuitement chaque jour dans
cette structure de 20 m² le matin à
partir de 9 heures sans rendez-vous et
l'après midi sur rendez vous la réponse
aux tests est donné sous 72 heures très
rapides très efficaces
bien reçu on est bien accueilli c'est
bien expliqué franchement c'est parfait
mais c'est vachement bien parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'attentât contrairement aux
laboratoires
oh bah je trouve une très bonne utile
activez elles sont toutes bonnes à
prendre ce moment le rendez vous était
rapide donc oui je recommande la
structure sera présente au minimum
jusqu'à la fin novembre le dispositif
pourrait être sûrement étendue au delà
de cette date
au total le département compte près
d'une quarantaine de centres de
dépistage est toujours aux chaînés
rocancourt mais aussi à montigny et à
guyancourt plus besoin d'aller à
l'horodateur pour stationner dans ces
trois communes
le stationnement est gratuit sur
l'ensemble du territoire communal est ce
comme pendant le premier confinement
jusqu'au 30 novembre minuit
dans un autre registre le recours déposé
contre le résultat des élections
municipales à la verrière vient d'être
déboutée par le tribunal administratif
de versailles
les habitants de la commune ne
retourneront donc pas aux urnes c'est
l'ancien maire nelly duthu encarté au
parti communiste français qui avait
lancé la procédure contre son adversaire
et désormais mère nicolas dainville
divers droite
elle voulait faire annuler le second
tour des élections de juin dernier qui
portait victorieux nicolas dainville
avec 58 voix d'écart dans ce recours
elle reproché au maire actuel d'avoir
distribué des masques à la population
pendant la crise et des billets d'entrée
au zoo de thoiry des accusations écartée
par le tribunal administratif
sur le même sujet un autre recours a
aussi été déposés aux chaînés rocancourt
la décision devrait tomber le 16
novembre prochain un recours déposé par
le maire sortant philippe rioux à
l'international enfin l'événement de ce
mardi 3 novembre c'était les élections
présidentielles aux états unis de
nombreuses familles franco américaine
vivent dans les yvelines
nicolas landry est allé à leur rencontre
dans la matinée il a recueilli leurs
impressions et le ressenti par rapport à
la situation électorale incertaine au
rythme des mouvements d etat bascule
entre joe biden ou donald trump elles
ont suivi les résultats des élections
présidentielles américaines depuis leur
maison à marie sur mauldre précis et sa
fille maya sont franco américaines elles
ont voté pour le candidat démocrate par
correspondance
ce matin à visiter dans l'incertitude
face à l'absence de résultats définitifs
je sentais une sensation de neurocité
d'anxiété et ça continue sa condition le
pays vraiment divisé télévisé a
complètement en deux entre les deux
camps et et la fécule forme pas déjà dit
que les clubs d'être vainqueur mais il
conteste quand même
l'égalité à 2 certaines vote c'est le
chaos total
wyss consignes michigan pennsylvanie le
scrutin devrait se jouer dans ces états
soutiens de joe biden maya et sa soeur
tessa n'y croit plus vraiment je me sens
blasé parce que j'ai ce pressentiment
que trump a gagné que bien sûr avant
c'était pas le cas je me j'espérais
comme comme beaucoup de personnes mais
là avec avec les résultats actuels où il
ya quelques state qui reste va chausser
dégoûté mais aussi je sais qu'au fond de
moi que trump puis va gagner c'est
presque sûr devant leur télévision tracy
maya et tessa assiste à un débat entre
amy porter représentante des démocrates
en france et nicolas conc'air porte
parole français des républicains
yvelinois d'origine il soutient le
président sortant donald trump
à ce stade il faut encore être assez
prudent quand bien même on est assez
enthousiaste sur l'issue du scrutin avec
ces derniers hésitent à pivot les swing
states qui sont michigan with comme
signe pennsylvanie qui nous donne assez
favorable sur ses états c'est franco
américain vivant dans les yvelines ont
tous voté par correspondance
c'est le cas d'alice jousselin habitante
de saint germain en laye j'attends je
suis patiente savoir convient et les
chronos mais les résultats définitifs de
ces élections présidentielles
américaines devraient intervenir dans
les heures ou les jours qui viennent
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi l'information revient
demain à 18 heures dans le 7-8 journal
présenté par grégory canale jusqu'avant
vous pourrez revoir toutes nos émissions
sur le site internet tv 78 points com ou
sur notre application mobile tv 78 et je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
[Musique]